sex fascinates me I will say as a
scientist or a scientific investigator
as a science educator it fascinates me
but as a guy it fascinates me no one's
exactly sure what the forest first
organisms word that had sex but there's
very reasonable theories about it and
very reasonable theories about why it
persists why it's so popular in nature
so you can observe bacteria exchanging
DNA through these little these little
pipes these pili and they exchange DNA
and they carry on and you can imagine
one of them exchanging big pieces of DNA
slowly and another one exchanging small
pieces of DNA quickly and so they would
then it is reasonable that two different
versions of the same strand of DNA the
same genes came to be one would become
the egg and the other would become the
seed or the sperm and you can it's it's
not hard to imagine after you absorb
these things under a microscope
exchanging BNA but then why would it
persist why wouldn't other bacterial
species let's say in the case of
bacteria why wouldn't other bacteria
out-compete the slow exchange fast
exchange versions just by budding off in
the traditional split yourself and a
half type of binary bacterial
reproduction well apparently your
biggest enemy is not lions and tigers
and bears which of course can be trouble
tell chem Iran
your biggest enemy is germs and
parasites so apparently by having sex
organisms are able to come up with a new
mixture of genes a new combination of
genes a new strand of DNA that the germs
and parasites are not able to disable as
readily are not able to hijack as easily
so this is such an important thing and
such a valuable innovation
that well you just think of all the love
songs that are written every five
minutes but just look at dandelions and
the lilies of the field I might add I
mentioned this in the book I think the
guys who wrote the Bible just kind of
missed that lilies in the field go to a
lot of trouble to make flowers it's a
lot of work and they don't spend it on
toil actually they're working pretty
hard and they do that to get a new mix
of genes because plants have viruses and
parasites as much as the next organism
so it's really quite an insight and the
guy who coined this theory is is
fabulous the theory of the red queen and
so Alice Alice in Wonderland is now in
through the looking-glass in the next
book and she meets the Red Queen the Red
Queen is some sort of chess piece person
and she's able to slide or she does
slide around on the chess board of life
somehow and when you're talking with it
you have to run so Alice says to the Red
Queen if you know where I come from if
you run all day you end up somewhere
else and the Red Queen says what seems
like a very slow but with a British
accent I presume seems like a very slow
sort of country and that's what
evolution is like if you're not running
all the time you fall off the treadmill
of life and your genes disappear so it's
quite an it's just a cool expression the
theory of the Red Queen and it's an
aspect of evolution that Darwin
speculated about but it wasn't really
figured out until a century later it's
really something
you